ernsthafte sport geboten bekommt und der
trifft zu hause gerne lassen
servus es geht sondern ist willkommen zu
einem weiteren video auf meinem teller
heute nehme ich euch mit zu meinem
training zum sport dem ich sozusagen
regelmäßig treibe und dazu gehen wir als
erstes mal runter ins auto
los geht das gesamtrating spd-kollegen
ich nehme das alles war so mit der
kamera auf weil es auf entspannter ist
und sieht man sich ja nicht gegen den
filmen mit dem iphone an das mikro nicht
zu halten
ich habe das mit dem iphone und gerade
so mal die in kamera habe ich mich ein
bisschen selbst sehen kann war natürlich
kein display herbst und mit ziemlichem
er wolle druck wäre so was wir hier auf
dem spiel plötzlich dem turnier auf den
plötzlich inszenierung die sonne brennt
ist wie ihr seht auf jeden fall weil wir
als erste mal an diese stange gehen
wenn wir erst ein paar klimmzüge
abreißen und dafür gegeben diesmal das
handy
schön so
doch und weiter im text
oberkörper
es gibt weiterhin auch immer so
denn hierbei weil man sie an der uni
aussieht auch immer die bayern ist sie
profi trainieren
denn das ist der landschaft und ganz
knapper aber jetzt nicht zu fitness
technisch wäre das was ihr von hier
kommt das ja anschauen diese perspektive
her
gerade jetzt wo die sonne scheint extrem
geil noch draußen zu trainieren
ich weiß nicht wie ich im winter macht
gehe ich wieder ins studio aber du
kannst ja kurz warum schwenken bis zum
fußballplatz dahinten möglichkeit sind
auf jeden fall 60 nicht immer trainieren
und zwar schon seit einem halben jahr
mittlerweile draußen
das kann ich jedem empfehlen der sagt
ich finde es langweilig nur die star
geht einfach auf die platz macht die
übung
sucht euch da irgendwelche überaus
wertvoll gemacht hat auf jeden fall echt
coole sache viel mehr spaß draußen und
es geht weiter mit den behinderten übung
mehrzahl überlegt welche übung ist noch
behindert kann sich noch lustiger aus
damit ihr haus zum lachen haben
so leute und eine sache hilft ihr
niemals vergessen die wichtigste über
umgebung sie an diesem schalter umlegen
fragen auf
für die besten games lockout naja soviel
licht auf jeden fall mache ich diese
ganze übung ist selten gezeigt habe
mache ich gegen hintereinander ohne
pause und das vier- fünfmal insgesamt ob
man richtig guten training training fügt
denn durch ein trainingseffekt natürlich
scheint es mal ausprobieren wollen macht
einfach mal unterliegt dafür stehen dass
ihr irgendwie auf das super trainiert
ist einfach cool macht mehr spaß als in
studie und ist kostenlos
ganz wichtig wir machen wieder auf dem
rückweg so leute das was von meiner
seite möchtest du dir gefallen hätte
gerne einen daumen nach oben da lassen
in die kommentare schreiben was euch da
ein feld gut ansonsten gehen zu sagen
bald ist morgen wald ist morgen morgen
wahrscheinlich pc da und da können wir
der minecraft nehme ich freue mich noch
gut